you see with Afghanistan and how the
Taliban now have more Blackhawk
helicopters than the entire British Army
because of Biden's absolutely cowardly
and and shameful Wayne which he withdrew
I've never been for the occupation but
the way in which he can't run in that
way was shameful and left them with all
those weapons so our own actions also
have to be put into the picture to
understand now as I say what one of the
things they all have in common is that
they are being weaponized for to fight
proxy wars and invariably you see the
case of Syria demonstrates that very
clearly because of our desire to remove
Assad who uh I come from a background
where all Arab dictators have been our
enemy I have no sympathy for Assad but I
what I wouldn't want to ever accept is
that we replace Assad with Al-Qaeda and
Isis which is what we were effectively
doing is what Trump brought to an end by
the way
um and I think to give you one final
example take Ukraine
and the as of Nazis who aren't even
neo-nazis they're actual Nazis they come
from the Bandera tradition which is the
surviving elements of Nazism and the
collaborators in uh in that uh in
Ukraine from the era of uh Nazism up
until today they are still there now as
of now every country has racists but as
of is a battalion that was integrated
into the Ukrainian Army and and formally
became their National Guard so the
Ukrainian National Guard is the azov
Battalion as of our Nazis this is not in
dispute this is not a opinion this is a
matter of fact I for 10 years ran the
world's first and leading
counter-extremism organization it was
our job to brief Prime Ministers and
presidents on who is an extremist I have
met in that Pursuit uh George Bush Tony
Blair David Cameron more heads of state
than I can imagine one-on-one talking
like this I am telling you as of our
Nazis this is not in uh dispute it's a
fact they have not seen Insignia and yet
we're sending weapons and funds to Nazis
who are integrated into the Ukrainian
Army that's like saying that because we
wanted to get rid of Assad we're going
to fund Isis you can't uh Run the World
in a way
where the ends justify the means because
then you have what people call
collateral damage imagine that in the
intellectual side of things you you are
we are funding and weap and arming
people who who have these extremist
ideologies and then we're surprised that
these ideologies spread now my job then
becomes harder because it's not just
against jihadism that I stand but of
course Nazism obviously which is how I
ended up in the first place becoming
radicalized so you've got people like us
saying look you know the world should be
about peace unity love and and meanwhile
the um governments that we are
attempting to counsel in that regard are
doing the exact opposite by arming and
funding these militia uh all over the
world can I just give you this isn't a
pushback this is more of a follow-up but
it'd be almost like if you were starting
a company right and you go to someone
like a PBR starting a company right now
and we go to some intelligence agency
for seed capital or to raise some money
okay so maybe they invest in our
business but at the end of the day we
started the business so it almost seems
like you're saying that the intelligence
agencies are facilitating or propping up
a lot of these uh terrorist groups and
that's like if you're peeling an onion
that might be the second third fourth
fifth layer but the bottom layer of the
onion of isil of al-Qaeda the Taliban is
the group itself it's not the
intelligence agencies oh it's my own
it's a yes and no it's a it's a mixture
of both because some of the leaders are
actually infiltrators from the security
services I mean there's only so far I
can go into this without being too
scandalous and uh let's get scandalous
here uh but also lives are at stake so I
I think that it's important to recognize
that especially Isis Isis itself is a
creation of these proxy wars especially
Isis where you're correct is the history
yes you're absolutely correct so how uh
um let's start with say um Islamic Jihad
in Egypt how that began
uh is the Muslim Brotherhood were
attempting to create their own version
of this kind of Theocratic thinking and
bring that about in Egypt
um which by the way that one year that
Morsi was in power the leader of the
Muslim Brothers after mubarak's
overthrow I mean ultimately as there's a
BBC hard talk interview of me with
Steven sacker where I'm criticizing the
Muslim Brotherhood government and he
says to me but weren't they elected I
said yeah just like Bush was and I can
still criticize George Bush so I I do
make the point that ultimately they were
elected they were better than a military
dictatorship which is again what we have
now with CeCe so my critique of them
isn't to strip them of the fact that
they were legitimately elected but let's
take the Brotherhood as an example
before this all happened because they've
been around since the 1920s
um they they they would be going about
their proselytizing in Egypt and of
course under the dictatorship they
weren't allowed and they would be thrown
into the jails now how they began
treating them is there's a big fortress
in Cairo it's called
is the Saladin Fortress it's now a
tourist site like the Tower of London
you go there you go into the dungeons
the London dungeon anyone been to the
London dungeon yeah you see all the wax
works of the torture they used to do
yeah so there's a fortress like that in
in Cairo except it's not historic it's
in our lifetime it was a torture dungeon
and prisoners that I was with in maserat
or a prison were held in that Fortress
which is an ancient Fortress but the
regime had converted it to a torture
dungeon now in that clinic The Fortress
uh they would get the Muslim Brotherhood
prisoners and they would basically
starve dogs for um a long time and then
the starving dogs would be let loose in
the solitary cell with these prisoners
to basically terrorize them and torture
them now this kind of treatment raping
wives in front of husbands torturing
children in front of fathers to force
confessions is how jihadism emerged in
the very prison I was held in so
mazaratura prison is
the infamous founding ideologue of
modern day jihadism who wrote the book
The Das capital of jihadism called
milestones
in Arabic now Milestones was written in
the prison I was held in and it was
written by a former Muslim Brotherhood
member now what you said by the way Adam
and I didn't mean to say you're all
wrong because that's where what you said
applies this is an example where we have
to take Muslims have to take
responsibility for what happened next so
he's very angry he's they've witnessed
all this torture he then does what I I
did the opposite of this right he then
codifies a dogmatic rigid way of
thinking to make themselves feel better
about the fact they're angry and that's
where Milestones came from and that was
the basis the intellectual basis for
modern day Al-Qaeda that emerged so
that's how what you said correctly is
how jihadism emerged is I don't think
said gutter was an intelligence
operative he was an angry man who had
been witnessed all of him and his
brothers would witness torture and they
are angry and then they codify their
anger in and justify it by Islam like
everyone does in any every Faith to
tradition I mean the Inquisition and the
Crusader example of that so he codifies
and justifies his anger and then writes
it in a book and that then then takes
off so yes that's how it began but by
the time you get to the end of it with
Isis more so than not Isis is a creation
of these proxy wars and intelligence is
why uh I have to be as candid as I am
about this because we've gotta everyone
has to take responsibility for what's
going on so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]